stat that's almost impossible to believe
more than one third of food is wasted
around the world that number jumps to 40
percent here in the U.S and that has
governments and the private sector
starting to act from biotech companies
looking to cut down on waste at the farm
level to a number of apps that are
trying to reverse it at the consumer
level including too good to go which
currently operates in 14 U.S cities with
the goal of going anywhere food is
wasted
so what are we looking at here so coffee
Cobble Hill Coffee Shop Right chocolate
poppies Claire oliverson is showing how
just a few swipes and clicks can save
money and a whole lot more so that's a
bakery and you'll see other things in
here so supermarkets also supermarkets
also so supermarkets tend to have a lot
of surplus and it's everything from
baguettes to an entire rotisserie
chicken right the app too good to go
allows grocery stores like Gourmet
Garage in New York
to get their perishable food surplus
into consumers hands at a steep discount
we always say put three times the value
so as a consumer you pay four dollars
five dollars six dollars and you get
twelve dollars fifteen dollars eighteen
dollars worth of value
too good to go is a six-year-old
certified B Corp based in Copenhagen
currently operating in 17 countries
oliverson runs its U.S marketing this is
food that would be thrown in the garbage
that's exactly it the reality is that
forty percent of food goes to waste in
this country and actually globally that
contributes to ten percent of greenhouse
gas emissions so food waste for a
country it would actually be the third
largest emitter of greenhouse gases
after the US and China that's because if
food isn't composted in soil it ends up
in landfills where it slowly converts to
methane gas which is 25 times worse for
the planet than CO2 so we talk about
this as a win-win-win first of all
saving food is a win for the planet have
a nice day you're helping local
businesses they're getting a little bit
of Revenue they wouldn't get otherwise
and it's a win for you you get great
food for a third of the price and one of
the things people that use the app love
the most is it's a surprise what you're
getting you don't know exactly oh my god
did you see this I don't think you
understand look at how many bagels I got
and seeing other people come back with
their hauls you can watch them on tick
tock on Instagram there's kind of
communities around it now just sharing
what is in that bag another muffin a
chocolate chip cookie that I just broke
this little pastry and two sandwiches
poppies in Brooklyn's Cobble Hill
Neighborhood has been working with too
good to go for nearly two years Jamie
Erickson says it's a perfect match for
her Cafe it's really hard to think this
food that you've spent so much time and
effort building and creating would sit
on the counter and be thrown away at the
end of the day it hurts our labor costs
if it's our food costs and so what we
would do is scale back on the amount of
food we would make to try to not have
that happen and then it's a balancing
active yeah so this kind of answered
that for us
on the day we visited coffee's bags
included assorted baked goods and a
fried chicken sandwich
and how do you like these apples all for
six bucks thank you so much
but before food even reaches the cafe
there's significant waste at the farm
level I studied at UPenn and in
Pennsylvania they grow apples so a good
place to start right Catherine sisoff
has found a way to save millions of
apples from spoiling I was applying to
grad school to go and study Neuroscience
okay and then I read that 40 of all food
is wasted before it's consumed which is
the craziest thing I've ever heard of in
my life and that was followed by a wave
of guilt and then an idea if you've
heard that One Bad Apple spoils the
bunch it's absolutely true and this is
because as the fruit is ripening it's
telling all the other fruit around it
that it's doing that and so they all
ripen together and they normalize to
whoever is the most right based on that
concept she started a company while
still at Penn called strella biotech
we met during the harvest season at one
of her first clients the rice fruit
company where apples from theirs and
neighboring orchards are washed sorted
and packaged
but to have apples for sale in stores
year round Millions need to be put in
storage without perishing it's like how
long do you store apples in this
facility
well it depends but Leighton rice is the
quality manager for at least say nine or
ten months and we do that every year
the apples are kept in deoxygenated
rooms between 33 and 37 degrees how'd
you know when it was like we should pull
these out and get these off to market
now well it's a it's a tricky decision
zizoff helped remove some of the mystery
so we typically put two sensors inside
every single room so they look like this
she developed sensors that monitor
emissions of the gas ethylene that
indicate ripening rice agreed to test
the technology in its early stages
though he wasn't exactly hopeful and I
said well you know this is new
technology and you know they're grad
students but they're not Apple people so
you know I'll humor them but I'm not
opening those rooms well sure enough
yeah we opened the rooms and there was
problems yeah so we're looking at is
maturity data Jay Jordan is co-founder
of strella Biotech from 60 it's really
stable whereas room 92 really takes off
and spikes it's producing a lot of gas
and so Leighton mccallison say which
Gator room do I open and let's say room
92 is taken off it's moving much much
faster so I would pack and sell that
fruit first strella biotech estimates
their technology saves up to 20 percent
of a Farm's yield they're currently
working with 70 percent of Apple
producers
at their research and development lab in
Philadelphia the company is working on
sensors that can be used for other fruit
everything from avocados to nectarines
to bananas
and they're working with grocery stores
too to ensure that quality fruit makes
its way onto the shelves so this feels
like you've hit this food waste at the
supply chain level at every level
I think that's how you make an impact
because when we think about food waste
we're like well why doesn't the grower
try why doesn't the retailer try they
are trying but there's only so much you
can do as an individual player within
the whole system as soon as you give
away your apples to the next person you
don't know what's going to happen and so
you kind of need a guardian of the
apples if you will that's making sure
that at every point along the supply
chain the right decision is being made
you are the Apple Guardian right now one
of one of many
[Laughter]
so if you're wondering what you can do
people say one of the best things
compost and that there's a law now in
California where people have to do this
now at the local level and they're
helping them think of it like recycling
they're offering that service where
they're able to do it grocery stores now
in California being required to actually
donate food that is not been used yet so
this is a way where we are finding ways
to not waste but reuse food to help the
environment help people keep down costs
yeah I'm just curious I use the garbage
disposal a lot is that considered bad or
should you compost compost when you can
compost when you can and as far as too
good to go it's obviously in big cities
right now and Claire oliverson told me
that they're hoping to make this more
rural but there are some challenges but
to Michelle's point you know even though
40 this number is sunny yeah 40 of food
is wasted nobody wants to waste the food
right no no you just have to figure out
ways and I think in California by making
it accessible by making composting
accessible for you people that does
change things that's something you have
to do